hey brandon hey theo this is dan in
tampa florida
and i've lived most of my life in
connecticut and recently i've been
having my friends reach out to me crying
about all the snow they get up there
and uh got me thinking maybe there's
some creative ways to get rid of the
snow
brendan i know you're from colorado so
i'm sure you've shoveled your share of
snow
and uh my question is boys king it or
sting it
flamethrower in your driveway gang gang
buzz buzz oh damn
daddy
that is gangster bro that is
savage it's doing the goddamn job though
a hundred percent how is this guy the
first guy to think of this
ah i bet you if elon musk took his ass
to aspen he'd be doing the same [ __ ]
elon mustard dude that guy's [ __ ] i
think
you're not buying elon musk you're not
elon musk fan
look i'm getting a tesla truck i will
admit it but
uh you would get a tesla truck did you
pay to get on the wait list
they're gonna be dope i'm considering
paying i have i have this tab open on my
web on my computer
oh you're talking about oh the truck i'm
thinking of the suv you're talking about
the truck truck
the square thing that'd be dope that
ain't for you that ain't for you bro
it comes with a hot [ __ ] in the back no
it comes with a handsome dude in the
back
hey dude i don't know that guy get out
of here man what's your name
what's your name yeah that thing is uh
what do you think king of her stinging
man i say look if this is this
neighborhood bowser this dude
is welcome to burn down the whole
[ __ ] neighborhood if he wants bro
you can use this to clean your driveway
you can use this to if your kid
sees you out there melting the damn yard
bro
you're like uh somebody that gives like
um
side uh hustles and final fantasy bro
you i think you've made it at that
legend this this [ __ ] fahrenheit 451
neighbor
this would be sick bro this [ __ ] would
be dope
he's also like the dude off running man
if you remember that super 80s movie
with arnold schwarzenegger
running man dude no thanks bro i'm in a
chick yeah
whatever keep lying to yourself
i'm not lying to myself dude i just read
in my diary yesterday that i am straight
you idiot your outfit says different son
yeah this isn't my outfit dude i
borrowed this from somebody who was
actually having a really tough day
90 who would sting it who the [ __ ] would
sting a flamethrower
there's nothing more badass than a
flamethrower the only thing that make
you more badass is throwing grenades up
in that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
now we're talking about snow grenades
yeah yeah doug
yeah from la to nashville son denim bro
denim bro don't do it denim bros
don't do it again uh he did it
so yeah ninety percent dude yeah if you
had a grenade i'm sorry nick if you had
a grenade that could eliminate the snow
in your yard
also once you do the yard you can go
straight and
barbecue some meat you know what i'm
saying like don't stop right there
that's what i'm saying keep that [ __ ]
going do your neighbor's lawn
do get a nice brisket out there [ __ ]
tan up your girl with the flames bro
tan up them cheeks if you want whatever
you want to do bro that's that's the
move do your neighbors
i've never been more appreciative than
when the the
neighbor with the snow snowblower comes
and does yours and you wake up and it's
done
dude little fact about my dad and snow
blowers
they're real triggering for the man
because when he was 17
he had a snow blowing business and the
snowblower got stuck
and my father was like oh you know what
it's stuck i'ma stick my hand in there
and on stick it
and it cut off three of his fingers so
my papa's hand they save two of them
my papa's hands like this i'll have him
send a picture of his hand to us for the
video
his hands like this so these two fingers
have fake knuckles and this one's
missing it
dude are you serious yeah swear to god
how is that the first time we've heard
that
i mean we've never talked about snow
blowers before it's not you know we're
usually in l.a this whole time you've
been telling us
about all this other [ __ ]
this and this i can't read but you
[ __ ] forgot to tell us
your father is missing 10 of his [ __ ]
grip tactics yeah bro and he lifts like
a [ __ ] but he has to lift with
gloves on because his grip's not great
but he's like a ninja turtle he these
four are strong as [ __ ]
like a sloth dog meet my dad at 2 15.
bro you think you're badass train that
[ __ ] jiu jitsu out there in
nashville
once you meet my dad at 2 15. see what
the [ __ ] up with his four fingers son
i put your dad in that hard scarf boy
come get it bruh
hush little baby
is